mais y toucher mais occupé de toi tu
resteras jean clientèle de minutes avec
la fois garé juste après d'accord je
montrais commandant s'élève sur l'album
de choristes important qu'à la chanteuse
dont la musique c'est non seulement une
oreille et le bush mais également
bassiste un bassin bercy et je vais vous
montrer comment danser ou very d'accord
parce que ça se danse à voulait qu'on
remette un peu tout le monde
ah oui là dedans c'est déjà sur toulouse
barak aurait on veut la corée en axel là
[Applaudissements]
da
gêné en matière combat et robert vous
avez déposé la craie l'inpi très bien
jean marie patry
l'accord est vraiment génial mais
toujours le mec il est c'est son corps
bouge
[Applaudissements]
là bas il ya deux à l'entrée
merci manière comique et si bercy jo
barry bonds les chéris quand on y est on
en train de caler le disque 1 c'est bien
c'est d'autres petits réglages sont
salis cheddar pas trop
voilà donc tu t'inquiètes pas feutrés
que s'est ouverte ce qui à 19 ans et
normalement le rap
ouais mais c'est comme ça en tout cas
sinon pire des cas on écoutera toute la
soirée on est tout le monde va pas non
plus d'en être
si cela vous est bon on se régale on
serait là on se régale vous verrez
l'émission est encore mieux quand on est
chez soi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
au life i 1
c'est du très haut niveau sur le chant
du cygne non ça c'est manque de sommeil
les gars on va démarrer par la une le
chant du cygne d'accord je vous montrais
voilà tu es toujours énervé quand vous
dans ce jour
voilà c'est l'intro c'est l'implosion
bois une seule dernière fils et ses
l'intro de chant des xinmin ont mis en
12 voilà c'est le chant du cygne elles
ont évolué alors mettez là douze comptes
dormants
[Rires]
alors ce jeu
tu dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tuniques et les cheveux janvier que j'ai
fait une cavani
[Applaudissements]
l'album de paris sans déconner on va en
fait m e m quand il a l'air bien l'album
est oui alors je dis c'est un album il
faut je viendrai avec l'album le danser
chez vous un